radical republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green has proposed a
national divorce saying the blue States
and the red states are just too
different now and we need to basically
separate in some way you know the
funniest thing about this is that the
red States as a country aren't viable
blue States subsidize red States blue
states have higher per capita incomes
blue states have better education blue
states have better infrastructure blue
states have better Access to Health Care
red states are much more likely to
depend on a single industry for their
entire State's economy compared to Blue
States if such a country were to exist
the red states of the United States of
America
it would be a country in trouble and
aside from all the other stuff about
secession and this that the other thing
the idea is absurd because they need the
blue States